now the fight against the delta variant
of the coronavirus
los angeles county now recommends
wearing masks
at indoor public places whether you're
vaccinated or not
roxanna siberia is following the spread
of the strain overseas
and the efforts to contain it outside
this english soccer stadium
young people are lining up to roll up
their sleeves
it's the first opportunity i've had to
actually get vaccinated and i'm looking
forward to
the uk is racing to vaccinate all adults
as the delta variant has driven new
covid cases to more than
20 000 in a day the highest figure since
february that's even though nearly 62
percent have been fully vaccinated
slightly more than in the us but in
countries like russia
and indonesia where vaccination rates
are much lower
the new strain is blamed for
overwhelming hospitals
and filling cemeteries and in australia
where tough border controls had helped
keep
cases in check a two-week lockdown has
now shut down
sydney it will become a very dominant
variant globally sharon peacock leads
the uk's efforts to map mutations of the
virus
can we beat this virus it keeps mutating
it's here
for good so people will become infected
but we know how to treat people we know
how to prevent infection
and we then learn to live with it
the english city of bolton shows one way
how
in early may with less than a third of
adults fully vaccinated
a rate similar to some u.s counties
delta sent infections
soaring but after door-to-door testing
and moving vaccination sites into more
deprived communities
covid cases have dropped almost in half
says vaccine director
dr helen wall for people who are
managing vaccine programs it's about
understanding why people are hesitant
because hesitancy isn't just about you
know not wanting it it's about not being
able to access it
dr wahl also told us that while some
vaccinated people are still getting
infected few are getting hospitalized
for dying
officials here in england hope as
vaccinations continue they can remove
all remaining restrictions in three
weeks a move delayed by the delta
variant
anthony roxanne lisa berry in london for
us thanks roxanna